you
[Music]
great so we're going to kick off the
last series of talks with Mike br6 from
from Sydney and he's going to talk to us
about quantum firmware and the role of
Quantrill in quantum computing so thank
you Thank You Krista for the invitation
to come in and talk this presentation is
going to be a little bit different
looking than the last few I'm an
experimentalist so I'll talk at a higher
level about some of the concepts that I
wanted to convey about this idea of how
quantum control plays into the way we
design or I think we might design
quantum computers but I'll also talk
about some experimental results from our
lab focused on the control of qubits
realized in trapped ions so very broadly
I'll follow this outline I'll give just
a little bit of motivation about why I
think and why I argue that control and
control engineering in particular will
play an important role in designing
quantum information systems I'll give a
tiny bit of background on the
experimental platform we use and then
I'll talk about a couple of specific
examples of the use of physical layer
control for addressing problems like D
coherence in quantum bits then one set
of new results focused on how quantum
control techniques can actually modify
the effective error model experienced by
real hardware to make it more compatible
with higher level abstractions by
quantum error correction and I'll talk
at the end about how some of these
things actually have kind of a feedback
loop in the design cycle on how you
actually design and architect the
quantum information sir
so so for me personally a lot of the
inspiration for the kinds of work that
my team pursues comes from lessons of
past technology developments and one
example that I quite liked and I
presented this before so some of you may
have seen it is the idea of looking back
at the origin of flight and so this
image is obviously at the Wright
brothers who famously achieved the first
manned powered controlled flight it's
important to say that because at the
time there was an entire aviation
industry and they were not the first to
fly they were the first to achieve this
very specific goal in the field
and that goal was quite elusive for a
long time and it was elusive in part
because there was conventional wisdom in
the community the conventional wisdom
was that one would design an aircraft to
achieve something called inherent
stability that effectively no matter
what the pilot did the aircraft would
keep flying in a stable way and the goal
of achieving inherent stability I mean
it got the industry quite far but
eventually that was completely abandoned
and it was abandoned because of the
developments that came in large part
from the Wright brothers who were
bicycle engineers and thought that
instead of isolating the pilot from the
system that they should give quite a lot
of control and so I like this particular
quote which says from the beginning
their goal was to VISAA to devise a
control system that would give them
absolute command over the motion of a
machine in every axis all the time and
if you're familiar with with their
particular prototypes you know that what
they what they did was they gave the
pilot the ability to control the shape
of the wing of the airfoil to the point
where it was almost unplayable by
anybody other than them but this idea
that control was an alternative
alternative approach to stabilizing an
otherwise dynamically unstable system is
now pervasive in engineering and it's
what shapes all modern aerospace
engineering so now let's think about how
this comes into the idea of building
quantum computers I take this graphic
from a paper by Cody Jones and Yoshi
Yamamoto that gives one particular view
of how to craft an abstraction or a set
of abstraction layers for designing a
quantum computer a lot of what we've
heard about today comes at these top
levels of the logical layer or the
application layer my talk is going to
focus on these bottom layers from the
physical the specific devices that we
use have form coherent effects through
the virtual where we apply controls and
then up towards quantum error correction
and I'll start talking just a little bit
about our physical system of choice so I
mean I'm an ion trapper I had done
postdoc with Dave Eiland our our
preferred approach is to trap individual
atoms
we do that using amo techniques that are
very common and have been around for
many decades this is a photograph of one
of our experimental systems this is a
altra high vacuum chamber where we
evacuate inside of that to about 10 to
the minus 11 tor and then what you can
see right in the middle there is a set
of four metal rods with a lens system
above them above those rods those rods
are used to form a quadrupole potential
and so this makes one looks a little bit
like a saddle by applying voltages and
you should think a hundred volts and
something like 20 megahertz when you
make this saddle the general concept is
that if you were to put a ball on a
saddle it wants to roll down the concave
down bit but if you're able to spin the
saddle at a rate fast compared to how
quickly it can roll down the hill you
can achieve stable confinement so with
charged particles we do the same thing
using a kind of electromagnetic saddle
this so-called pseudo potential allows
us to achieve stable charged particle
confinement we trap ions in various
different configurations what you're
looking at are photographs on a CCD
camera of two different species on the
Left you terbium on the right beryllium
in linear pull traps like I told you
about a moment ago we trap things very
very similar to what you see on the left
from single ions down to small chains of
ions we have a whole separate program in
my group that's focused on a very
different kind of trapping technology
called the penning trap where we achieve
stable confinement of large crystal and
arrays of ions this is a picture from
when I was at Myst what you see is that
you can get this triangular lattice in a
native way and have a spin 1/2 on each
so this is a nice platform for quantum
simulation for today's talk I'm going to
focus exclusively on this top left image
the idea of one ion as a quantum bit and
of course if you're familiar with amo
physics you know that our our set of
tricks focuses primarily on looking to
the internal level structure of the atom
as the source of a quantum coherent
manifold if this kind of diagram is not
very familiar to you as an amo physicist
it doesn't matter all I'd like to do is
call your attention to the fact that
there are transitions in the optical
near 370 nanometer
that we can use here to cool our ions
and then there's a splitting in the
ground state of the energy level
structure that we use as a two-level
manifold this two-level manifold is our
qubit we assign 0 & 1 to its near twelve
point six gigahertz which is very
convenient because that's in the
satellite communications band and
there's a ton of infrastructure that we
can employ and we can look to
experimental expertise from NMR or EPR
or general atomic physics developed over
many decades to understand how to
manipulate this two-level system
importantly that two-level manifold is
differentially coupled to the optical
field such that if we are in one
particular state the one stay here we
shine on the laser at 370 nanometers
it's bright and we can take a picture of
that and if it's in the down state we
shine on the laser and we don't see
anything this is how we do projective
measurement so we have the ability to
control the internal state of the ion
using microwaves at twelve point six gig
we can read out optically and perform
strong projective measurement we can
also do state initialization now while I
won't talk about it today it's also very
nice that in addition to the internal
degrees of freedom we also have access
to external or extrinsic degrees of
freedom in particular the modes of
motion of the ions they're kind of like
marbles in a bowl that slosh back and
forth those modes of motion can be
described as quantum harmonic
oscillators we can control those quantum
mechanical harmonic oscillators in order
to achieve coupling between the spin
degree of freedom or the effective spin
on these ions and that's how we perform
two qubit gates I'm not going to talk
about that today but it's important in
the context because you can go through
some of the metrics associated with how
well ions perform they're actually quite
nice in a variety of ways and you can
argue of course but I would I would say
that they're probably the leading
technology in terms of development if
nothing else they've been around as
quantum bits in that particular sense
for a very long time the kind of
lifetimes we achieve are are very
routinely of order several seconds if
you try hard keyboard Kym just did a 10
minute experiment but things like that
had been demonstrated back in the 1980s
as well the effective energy relaxation
time is
is something immeasurably long because
of selection rules that prevent decays
the way we do these operations on the
qubits using in our case microwaves give
us very high operational fidelity so
infidelities about five by ten to minus
measured by a couple of different
techniques to qubit gate Fidelity's in
the ninety nine point three to 99.9
percent raid range achieve by groups
like Innsbruck gate durations of order
ten microseconds processors that are up
to typically about twenty I on that's
what Chris Monroe and I'm cure using
it's also what the Innsbruck team has
been using fully controlled twenty cubed
coherent processors
inq is targeting forty nine and 2018
from what I understand so all the sizes
are quite competitive one thing that's
really quite nice is the the fact that
the architecture has what you might call
reprogrammable connectivity you can
achieve anything from kind of nearest
neighbor pairwise interactions through
to all to all fully connected graphs and
a reconfigurable approach I've heard
gave mooring from I on cue maybe at my
prompting now start to refer to this as
a quantum at the idea that you can
reprogram the connectivity in the
architecture on the fly now it's all
very nice it's it's a little bit of
advertising for the community but the
important message is that as good as
they are they're not good enough
and I think that's a message that
everybody here would appreciate the
question is what can we do to improve
them aside from making a better
microwave system or the hardware
improvements that will continue
irrespective of anything else so now I
want to step up from the physical layer
to the so-called virtual layer where we
talk about control and how control can
be deployed to address this specific
problem how can we improve the
performance of quantum hardware using
control the the specific example that I
like here is one that's very familiar in
computer engineering this is a
cross-section micrograph of DRAM and if
you're familiar with the RAM you'll know
that each cell each storage bit
is composed of one capacitor and one
transistor and if you write charge onto
the capacitor it's a 1 if there's no
charge to 0
you know something quite remarkable
about DRAM is that at some point in the
past decision was made by people I don't
know and I don't know how this happened
I would love if any of you actually know
the story behind this I'd love to hear
it but it was about a problem that they
had an engineering DRAM the the problem
is that the capacitors are leaky and
over time when you put charge into the
capacitor as it gradually just leaks
into the into the substrate it's kind of
like having a bucket with lots of holes
in it
the decision that was made that I think
was quite profound was to say well we
can try to patch the bucket we can try
to make it not leaky or we can give up
on that because that's a hardware
solution that can be quite costly and
just say if we just refill the bucket
every once in a while we can keep it
full and so this led to DRAM refresh so
whether you are familiar with it or not
roughly at a kilohertz rate so once per
millisecond all the DRAM in your
computer all the cells are refreshed
there's a voltage strobe all the ones
get refilled with charge and the zero
stay empty and this was a decision that
in my view has only a user and a novice
and the technology was quite remarkable
in driving DRAM to this highly
commoditized product it took what could
have been a huge semiconductor
development effort and turned it into a
control effort where the control is all
in software effectively so how does a
control engineer look at this kind of
problem and how do we think about it in
our system in qubits right we know that
qubits are impacted by their
environments it leads to decoherence
this is a big motivation for a lot of
the Microsoft efforts in topological
qubits in my honors what a what a
control engineer would typically do at a
high level is write down something like
this this is called a block diagram
where we talk about the plant that's the
thing we want to control for us it's
saying a qubit there's a controller that
acts on it maybe there's some sensor and
some feedback loop what's really nice
about this kind of approach is that
you've completely extracted away the
microscopic nature of whatever the
physical system is
and with this kind of block diagram
there are just rules that tells you how
a given input maps to a given output you
don't have to go through all the first
principles calculations and say the time
domain you just know that the output
state is related to the input state by
this thing called a transfer function
which is the forward path over 1 plus
the product of the forward in the return
path there are rules about this and it
makes it extremely powerful and that's
what I would argue is what has allowed
us to achieve really tremendous things
in systems integration in systems
engineering what we want to do is see
what lessons can be learned and ported
to the case of controlling quantum bits
where many of the rules are different we
know that measurement is very costly
because it destroys quantum coherence
and the like
so what I'll focus on in this talk
although our group does work in all
parts is this top part of the of the
diagram for getting the feedback loop
and achieving what's called open loop
control that is measurement free control
DRAM refresh is an example of open loop
control the strobe just happens once in
millisecond doesn't measure if the cells
are empty or full so if we quantum eyes
this just a little bit we can think
about some input state some output state
as here a function of time where your
qubit is now going to be subjected to
some stochastic process described by its
spectral properties and you can perform
by the controller some set of time
domain operations of su tubes they could
be Clifford operations or the like and
let's just call that a quantum circuit
here composed of some arbitrary set of
clifford's what we want is something
like that transfer function framework
that I told you about for that allows
this block diagrammatic approach to
systems engineering and classical
technology it does not it has not
existed in quantum technology in the
same way for these nonlinear systems
qubits are nonlinear which makes this a
very challenging problem and lots of
respects but my group is focused on this
quite a lot and and you know you can
understand some of the complication if
you say well my output state here at
time T is just the time evolution
operator on sy of 0 fine you write that
as the exponentiated Hamiltonian
operator where the Hamiltonian can be
a time varying quantity then you realize
that there's a part of the Hamiltonian
that describes your control and then the
part that describes whatever your
environment is and then you realize that
the noise and the control may well not
commute right so you could have Sigma X
terms and Sigma Z terms simultaneously
this becomes very challenging from in
certainly in the time domain and so what
we worked on was bringing this as a
transfer function into the Fourier
domain where we tried to write down and
we eventually achieved the ability to
write this thing F of Omega the transfer
function which describes arbitrary
control it describes it in the Fourier
domain the nice thing is that for
arbitrary piecewise constant control it
can be very complicated control profiles
in time we can write down the transfer
function capture all the issues of non
commutativity of these different
Hamiltonian terms and we then use those
in order to craft controls that are
suitable for what we want to achieve
what's particularly nice about that is
that it takes a complicated calculation
of what what do I expect my measurement
my error to be in a particular operation
and it turns it into a kind of simple
heuristic argument the heuristic is that
the amount of error I have in this
particular formalism is just given by
that filter transfer function which I
can calculate for arbitrary control and
the spectrum of the noise right just
that overlap integral is enough to know
in this case to first order what's going
on here which means that you can think
of if you craft that thing in the right
way you can think of it like a filter so
I have some noise described by a
spectrum my qubit is subjected to it but
then I apply the right control to my
qubit that effectively filters it and I
change the effective spectrum for
instance I reduce the low frequency
content in general these controls are
they behave like high pass filters they
suppress low frequency things the
underlying physics of course is the
physics of coherent averaging this is
something that we call dynamic error
suppression and it's very powerful it's
broadly used in our community this is
just an example from from quite a number
of years ago already where we're
applying two different control protocols
on trapped ions we're looking at how
well our state is
if the graph is on the low side of
things that's good that's low error
probability as you add more control
operations the lifetime of the state
improves like that's fine the important
thing is that the overlaid lines are not
fits
they have sorry these are these are bits
they have one free parameter which
rescale this noise spectrum which we
measure classically with the spectrum
analyzer these are magnetic field
fluctuations in the lab you see they
agree quite nicely in particular the
presence of that one spur near 53 Hertz
that came from sorry a hundred and fifty
three Hertz which came from a water
chiller three labs down the hall is
entirely responsible for the bumps and
Wiggles that you see at these
intermediate times right so you really
do gain predictive control at a very
fine level of detail by writing down
these transfer functions even for
reasonably complex control protocols and
of course you can suppress errors and
extend lifetimes I wanted to say very
briefly that this is something that
we've looked at outside of our Cuban
architecture we've done some
calculations looking at my honor devices
where you believe you'll be susceptible
to classical voltage fluctuations these
are these are things defined in
semiconductor superconductor hybrid
system there are voltages around and
despite exponential suppression in well
in variations in this Sigma V term
associated with the separation of the my
honors on a particular island in this
nanowire configuration jitter in that
can still cause problems and we showed
that using the filter transfer function
techniques we could calculate
approximately for kind of realistic
noise voltage causing jitter on those
things what kind of error rates we would
expect for in this case the t gate like
we heard before and we could get factors
of about a hundred to a thousand
improvement by using dynamically
corrected gate synthesis approaches
which just involves moving the meijer
honors in a particular pattern right you
can also suppress the Sigma X terms if
you do the right thing the point of
course is that if you can make a better
primitive T Gate and then feed it into a
magic state distillation the amount of
overhead required in the distillation
and will be reduced the same argument is
reducing error rates for quantum error
correction we've done quite a lot of
work in this field I just wanted to
point out that that Ken and I have done
work in this looking at applying these
same techniques to gain you understands
about understanding about composite
pulses from NMR and answering some fun
questions from that community as well
now I wanted to take one kind of step
half step up and look at this
intersection of the virtual and quantum
error correction layers here where the
motivation comes from the collaboration
I have with with monitor blat scheme as
part of the equal consortium the encoded
qubit alive team where our effort is
focused on bringing control engineering
expertise into the effort to build a
logical qubit the important concept is
that the fundamental assumptions that
make quantum error correction work are
incompatible with realistic laboratories
right the idea that all errors are
independent and identically distributed
is just not reality right it's
mathematically convenient I understand
that but instead we have correlations in
space and time one kind of correlation
is just that the noise can exhibit
temporal correlations here is a totally
contrived numeric example where I show
some noise that had some block
correlation length what happens of
course is that the correlations and the
noise are translated to correlations in
the error in those underlying gates so
this is just a calculation that you can
do for an arbitrary randomly compiled
unitary that ultimately implements the
identity you can calculate what is this
error vector so these are unitary
coherent errors they're not it's not the
depolarizing channel or anything like
that with this block correlated noise
and you look at what is the magnitude of
that error operator if you will and you
can calculate the autocorrelation you
see as the noise correlation grows
obviously the error correlation grows
there's nothing surprising here but this
is a challenge because this violates the
underlying assumptions of qec in some
way we want to understand what exactly
is going on and measure these
correlations and then see if there's
anything we can do about it the big
challenge of course
we can only measure at the end of the
circuit right that's something that
everybody understands I think the
insight into how to achieve this comes
from just measurement science from
metrology this is a totally random
numeric example I just generated noise
in MATLAB or whatever the important idea
is that if you have a process that has
some variance of its outcomes if you
average averaging reduces the variance
right so as you go from the black data
to the red data which are just averaged
in a moving sense the variance Narrows
from the black to the risk that's
something that I think is familiar to
most of us this however assumes that all
of those measurement outcomes are
uncorrelated that this is a white
spectrum if instead you do something
really simple that's familiar from the
clock community like you add a linear
drift term then the same averaging has a
very small impact on the measured
variance of outcomes this is very
familiar if you look at Alan variants
and clocks or anything like that so we
we ask can we do something simple what
can we average over and for us we can
average over randomly compiled circuits
that implement the same net unitary so
here what I'm showing is a set of
experiments where we measure the
Fidelity's or the error of different
circuits that all implement the identity
with two different noise processes
applied one with uncorrelated noise so
fast fluctuating and the other would
strongly correlated noise now there's
there's quite a lot of work that goes
into understanding the shape of these
distributions it comes from randomized
benchmarking and I'm happy to answer
questions but really the question here
is how did that variance that width
change as a function of averaging over
noise and what you can see is that if
you start with this correlated noise as
a function of averaging over engineered
applied noise again experiments you see
that the variance we may fluctuate
around but it saturates at some fixed
level which we can actually calculate
analytically but in the case of the
uncorrelated noise it a ver ajiz down
approximately like 1 over N and the
curvature and things are our things that
we understand via some work with Tom
Stace this is the difference between the
first crazy color graph I showed in the
second right the idea of this
correlation leading to a saturation in
the variance remember oh that's
unfortunate
now anybody see that where are we
sorry
actually I'm not going to apologize
okay so so let's remember now this idea
that the dynamic error suppression
approaches act like filters and they can
suppress low-frequency noise if you end
up with a noise spectrum that looks
whiter at the end then when you started
you've made the error spectrum less
correlated and so now let's go back this
is the same graph I just showed you and
on the right instead I'm always applying
strongly correlated noise except I've
replaced all of the gates in my circuit
on the blue line with dynamically
corrected gates and you see that the
scaling looks as if the error model has
been transformed from strongly
correlated to effectively uncorrelated
to within the limits of the measurement
by the action of the dynamical
decoupling or dynamic error suppression
approaches this to me is really powerful
because it says that instead of worrying
about coming up with totally new quantum
error correction protocols or having
much nastier fault tolerance thresholds
by adding control you can map the error
model to one that is more mathematically
convenient for qec now just at the end
here for the last couple minutes I
wanted to address how all of these
things can be linked together by
thinking about control because what I
haven't told you about is what the
control should look like in principle
you can do really crazy looking things
with your control you have in our case
full control in time with reasonably
high bandwidth over the amplitude the
frequency the phase of your control
fields that's effectively infinite
freedom it's both a difficult
optimization problem which brings with
it something called a lack of model
robustness that if the parameters
against which you're optimizing change a
little bit everything breaks but it also
becomes extremely demanding on the
classical hardware that has to implement
this stuff and the question is can we be
a little bit more clever and can that
feedback with the architecture of the
system well the approach that we take
looks at these mathematical functions
called the Walsh function there's square
wave analogues of the sines and cosines
and going back to to a number of
projects we've done in my group we've
learned that the Walsh functions allow
us to craft controls that are not only
in some cases unique solutions to
modulation patterns for
dynamically corrected non-trivial
operations or give you the timing for
dynamic decoupling pulses but also
actually encompass almost all of the
techniques developed in both NMR and EPR
and quantum information through
completely ad-hoc and totally different
physical mechanisms Walsh
modulation encompasses almost all of
them which is beautiful because now you
have a single mathematical framework in
addition I think it's beautiful because
of the nature of these functions as by
valued square waves now I'll tell you
more about that in just a second but
it's worth pointing out that there's
been a lot of activity in this field the
black things are from my group but we've
also seen recently the extension of the
use of these Walsh functions for
constructing unit Ares for instance
Krista's group and and Alana's Peru have
both worked in this there's a whole
range of things that can be done with
Walsh functions they're obviously very
well known in classical electrical
engineering it's very exciting to me to
apply them in this different context
that excitement really comes from the
fact that they have a really tight link
to digital hardware the Walsh functions
have this beautiful representation that
in the pit so-called Paley ordering the
elf walls function can be written as a
product or a mod to sum of square waves
of clocks that are easy to generate in
digital hardware so if you write out L
in binary every time there's a 1 you add
the appropriate Rademacher so if it's
Walsh 12 which one one zero zero you add
R 3 R 2 when you get that function
that's great because that's something
that we can do in an FPGA extremely
easily right so this is an example of
using look-up tables with very low
bandwidth overhead we can craft the
Walsh functions in real time we can then
extend that to make full-fledged
controllers in the Walsh basis where we
apply Walsh timing we have Walsh
modulated continuous output waveforms
from a D to a all in FPGA with
improvements of over a hundred thousand
times in the required resources or in
latency to reprogram Dianna
this is a circumstance it's just a toy
demonstration but it's a circumstance in
which having some knowledge of the
underlying physical system and the
physics of the quantum control can allow
you to architect controllers that are
far more efficient and this is a great
way on in my view to save on resources
so I'll just quickly summarize that
we've talked a little bit about the
importance of physical layer control for
quantum information from the from the
physical qubit improvement through to
its impact on quantum error correction
we've talked a little bit about how this
classical quantum interface can be
improved using these the physics of
quantum control we do a lot of other
things like machine learning for
predictive control and clocks and
quantum simulation I'm happy to chat
with anybody who's interested but I'll
just at this point acknowledge my group
and thank all of you for your attention
great thank you Mike other questions for
Mike great I have one question about the
use of all functions so it's kind of
looks over an eyes that you know and you
do digital stuff he actually has this
nice step functions but this is not what
happens in real life right because I'm
sure but it doesn't matter which is
quite amazing so what you see here it's
a great question and it's like you know
what is the first referee criticism of
these things what you find is that it
doesn't matter what the underlying
nature of your pulser is right so the
idea is in the architecture you separate
the generation of your high spectral
purity carrier like a 12.6 from whatever
does the modulation so each segment in
this case so this is a gate that applies
a PI rotation of the qubit right a bit
flip each segment is a Gaussian it can
be square or it can be a Gaussian and
that's easy to engineer in anything but
wall synthesis then just tells you what
the amplitude the relative amplitudes of
those Gaussian segments have to be you
can replace them with trapezoidal
functions you can replace them with
anything the the optimization values of
what the Walsh synthesis will be will
change but you can still always
emphasize in wall functions
so this is basically just convenient way
of representing when you like turn on
some switches on for your carrier
basically yeah it's so so this this
would be like the the inq waveforms that
you spit out from a DJ that modulate the
amplitude of your pulses okay thanks are
there any other questions from it no
it's not let's think like again for a
great tough
[Applause]
and now we're going to hear from
Matthias destroyer and he's going to
speak about whether or not a eyes can
dream of shooting her cat yes so did
that work was done mostly by my postage
to set the color who about the a year
half ago asked me whether a ice can do
quantum physics and whether that can be
better or not than what we've what we do
normally and I told you ok well there's
a big hype in AI so yes it's worth
trying
definitely however I honestly do not
believe that just taking a bought some
machine and thinking it can no quantum
many-body states much better than things
we've worked on for decades to optimize
is a bit naive a ice just cannot be that
good when the minterm has rather bit
more about their eyes I think it should
not have been so skeptical because as
we've seen this is the edge of a AI this
week and it is that simple neural
networks as idler so you can be
amazingly good at learning quantum
physics what we think is hard it may not
be as hard if you just let an AI learn
it so they must somehow dream about
swelling ask at what we want to solve
here is not self driving cars or
whatever but we want to solve the
quantum many-body problem we start with
the 50 destitute estimate onea the last
one atom spin as ever with some coupling
set between them and then we want to
solve either the the sisterhood busy the
yeah the after I got the eyee problem
and find the ground state or were to
solve dynamics if you want to do that
exactly then we start in a basis and we
look at the amplitudes in those basis
states for example for the 50s
in models this can be the secret is here
again states of the spins and I want to
look at the applitools of each of the
United States so a test attempted to
write down the wave function that takes
exponential memory and we cannot go
beyond about under spins or so even if
you turn the whole little computer but
we can do millions of spinners done 16
million spins East's since the player
decades ago with the quantum of the
color sampling we can turn the quantum
system into an egg replacer the other
part integral in machinery time we
sample the past and as long as the model
is stochastic the means as long as the
weights are positive this works very
well the sample the efficient then in
the sample the relevant states so though
there are many states the ones that
contribute are smaller and if we example
from them that's good enough we don't
have to look at all states to catch a
sample we can also look at matrix
product states that the compact
representation shell of states e instead
of top mega exponentially many vinegar
calculate the coefficients I write the
wave function was for some values of
spin Sigma IC 2 2 Sigma MZ as the
product of matrices so that's a compact
the platanus pass the presentation that
works extremely well in 1d systems are
there a few couple chains so we have
found lots of great representations in
many cases but they don't always work
quantum Monte Carlo works as long as
there's no sign problem
but when it's Fermi on so when it's
real-time dynamics it takes down the
matrix further states work well as long
as bigoted entanglement is low so most
plain 1d systems and for short time a
different evolutions to go further we
need new ideas and now the question is
which is to think hard and we need just
a building and carrier student to do it
or can a machine just do it can we just
have an AI that can translate languages
as we've seen to automate the archive
cars
discover drugs can also help us a little
bit with physics and that's what my
postdoc after seductive Nia teaches that
we wanted to try and so the idea was the
way he describes what you want to do is
we look at the brain and the brain is
basically a function that takes some
input into two atom output I look at
here I see a face and always crest up
for example and we just is to find the
weight and the functions that make this
work and the that's what I learn and we
say Candace also learned a quantum
system now this is as close to a brain
as the swag Macalester yield cow but
it's good enough so AI is old AI apply
to quantum mechanics is what we write
and the idea is basically given a basis
state so given for example the C values
of my quantum spins I want to know what
is the wave function so basically we
want to learn the wave function and
train the network to say if I have has
been set up up up down down up up down
that it predicts the wave function value
that's what I want to learn when I look
at that then I'm skeptical or I was
but basically this is nothing but the
variational wavefunction answers we have
some function that we want to optimize
and people have thought a lot about
optimize just or many body correlated
wave functions that are really finely
tuned to it or similarly the dimetric
subset or the states are really finely
tuned to 1b there's lots of physics that
goes into it and now what you set aside
is let us just use a restricted
Boltzmann machine so instead of putting
all of this quantum physics let us just
assume an IV model on this graph we have
some ating spins that correspond to the
C values of my quantum spins these are
the visible spins and they add another
layer of hidden spins these extra
classic lysing spins that the sky period
that then should model all of the
quantum mechanical nature of my quantum
many-body state and the more one during
a hidden ten gap with the variables I
choose the better the representation
should become the model then for the
wave function in this this certificate
restricted Boltzmann machine is simply
the partition function of this Ising
model I have the hidden variables the H
is neither spins I have turn negative
visible once the sin theta Sigma Isis
which basically clamp down because for
certain value of those I want to know
know what this the wave function and
basically the wave function is the
partition function of my aging model
given these specific values for the
visible space and they want to learn the
couplings in the Ising model
fields and couplings and the more hidden
is there as I have the more parameter
the better it may learn it
so then you first looked at a ghoul
state yes we can just put in complex sex
numbers here content of optimization
learning complex near so here is easy
later if the see I just want to say with
it under then I want to find the ground
state for example want to minimize the
energy the complex numbers get a bit
more complex when I want to actually
learn from a quantum experiment let's
say somebody gives me a quantum computer
with a thousand cubits I want to learn
the state the way I do it there is after
two two measurements and various pages
have such to change the basis the
measurement in the basis that way can
then again learn all the phases so for
the ground state I sample so I just
choose some values of the intensity
intensity parameters and that is our
standard that negative variational
pivotal statement the color methods
which mental stock they worked on for
decade already so that was standard it
just plucked in the facility a pill IBM
model and so you start with some guess
for the template parameters you
calculate the energy you want to then
optimize it find apparel you change
parameters and so on until you find the
best possible solution the way he one
finds it for example is by looking at
the energy and gradient so I take take
cancer example the system and measure
the energy I measure the gradients and
then I do a step in the next to
castigate gradient descent and slowly
hopefully move towards the optimum
the way we get the the gradient is we
don't measure the gradients that the the
the Whittle template forget it two
different well back up different ways
but we energy literally click ecliptic
calculate the gradient so that the
derivatives of the answers with respect
to the testing parameters enter and then
I need to sample expectation values of
those both negative the reuptake alien
term is basically the terms in the model
love answers and the energy and that's
what the sample and then I take a step
and when I and I got impressed it when
he then showed me this is a 1d
Heisenberg model length 40 he showed me
that if he has four times more hidden
layers than visible spins if he assumes
the model is translation invariance
which just has four and weights to
adjust then after doing about the
hundred iterations the energy is
converged to about five digits couldn't
in the noise so it just perfectly gets
the ground state of that for this pin
Heisenberg model with just four times
more hidden layers so it's not a big
answers when one then looks at models
without the side problem where they can
really know the ground state energy from
q MC like a 1d transverse field v nagar
I think a model like hundred the weight
basically it goes down to tiny tiny kind
tiny Cavalli's indicated this is the
errors with just two hidden layers
at the the security points it's worse
away from it it's trivial but it goes
down exponentially in the number of
hidden layers for cube of T if the
hiding pairs model of four times more I
think spins then quantum spins it's
converged to about five digits already
for 2d it's harder there's the testing a
much much much more to learn but with
about two four eight times more I think
spins than quantum spins this is the
best available variational wave function
that exists for the Heisenberg model
well if so this then is the heart
leaping really impressed bidness I said
well these Disney a restricted Boltzmann
machines to be really powerful for some
reason that I don't yet understand but
they can learn quantum mechanics pretty
well what does it look like no so here I
show the way first for a one the Dean
together to get the Ising model with
four times more mana hidden lay spins
then I give visible once and because I
know the Hamiltonian is translation
invariant and making answers that the
weights are also translation then I
guess you have two invariant then I'll
just show what is the weight of one spin
spinning in the center coupling to the
neighbors and this is these are the ways
that it learned so it seems to be quite
short range I think that's what they see
but also we see we don't really see much
in what is the physics of lipsticks
they've learned that that's quite common
men in and then again your girl got
sucked into network we don't really see
mmediately what it learn but just that
it works this is the
hasn't that model it's much longer
ranged in 2d we have happier negative 10
times more must means and we see they're
all learned some correlations local so
there are all kind of correlations at
certain distances it learns a bit down a
bit to the right which to the left and
so on it would be nice now to understand
that optimizing - maybe guide is a bit
but it's learning correlations extremely
well so these are static properties for
models that are so classic there's no
sign problem so this for test cases
where we be new energy to the looking
that that may be easy it would be great
to now see okay let's go to more models
but first we did something hard and
Emily went to dynamics that's when it
gets hard immediately because because
New Yorker the governor the quantum of
the color breaks down immediately we
can't do much so here what you want to
do is you want to evolve the
wavefunction in time we write down the
time belushin equation of fog getting a
subject is more time step we write down
the time evolution for the beta version
unsub's assuming some time dependence of
the wait and then I want to choose those
ways that this equation is as close as
possible to that one here and as I do
by taking this one and that's one it
take together you put in a product for
the pretty basic states then I get an
equation that the the negative the
derivatives of the consensus parameters
are then related to to to to to the
correlations between my operators and
the energy medication Sampras and then I
take a set
we stand adhere for one defense versus
the fitnah girls after we got the Ising
model and the 1d you - a pet model well
that we quench quickly poisoning a
highly gifted non-equilibrium and things
work pretty well for times about two or
three we where it starts getting hard
even for for negative we got symmetry
calculations so it works amazingly well
also for dynamics what is it recently
issues okay we don't just want to
minimize the energy of a model we don't
just want to look at the time evolution
but can we learn a quantum state so can
this be useful for quantum state
straightening up that interrupted
tomography it's okay let us take a
quantum system that we get from math to
quantum magnate maybe or from a negative
quantity our computer and we want to
learn the wave function by measuring my
qubits building up a model and then I
want to predict properties of it so just
want to measure the wave function
example and based on that I want to
learn learn as a representation now when
we did that we did not have access to a
hundred cubic lattice
so which okay let's just take the
thermal state for example of that kind
of bursts Pete Peters Nagar with the Big
Apple adjusting to the IV model or a
Gallagher of that vinegar Toronto
okay yeah - Parris okay model we
learn the wave functions and then we
looked at the
the Latian functions between I and J
this is the full one this is the one
that is reconstructed from the model we
learned and this works pretty well
though the thought can one use the to
calculate and the tentacles meant when
together I get the enthalpies with
charge how to measure and the answer is
yes it works amazingly well the solid
points are the the entanglement entropy
that we calculated from the model we
learned from local measurements here for
the b- i think a model and here for the
hasn't sent the peg model and it works
again extremely well which was
surprising at least to me but that just
just means that i probably
underestimated the power of a is well i
always debated how smart to be arguing
physics that we know how to do things
directly so that has started the
beginners play now many people
started to look into that and I think as
we build quantum computers personally
you think if the AI for learning about
quantum states will be coming again
coming up that this one more important I
want to end by summarizing give us I spy
a negative negative textures you gotta
gotta make up with other groups oops
oops new leadership the shunt cut the
Samus coop coop and mega others shows
that those states can represent
since negative Falacci Chaldea 32 states
well they can can exactly describe the
negative the negative total code state
for example directly it was also shown
by that group that the states can
represent states with the volume
intercepted or entanglement system done
like this the NPA states which has Verna
gotta pick up the you got the area law a
Chinese coop has shown that all of those
days can be represented by MPs States
about the MPS states may need to have
exponentially large bond dimensions so
it's sometimes exponentially better than
an ampere states and recently people
show those off so what is the what can
be if they represent a tisket with it
and it turns out that the F is IBM's can
represent most interesting physical
states well there are some states that
they can't really do well but mostly in
mahathat the most interesting your
states can be learned by a conflicted or
can be represented by a restricted the
abortion machine the challenge will be
how can we learn it efficiently in all
cases where do you want to go next
there's a lot that we can do new state
tomography counseling dynamics I we want
to look into can we use it to describe
quantum circuits so if for example
google comes and wants to show Kanto
supremacy with the circuit the question
is can an AI actually learn these wave
functions and representative requested
that you Testament lis students e
where's the rear threshold for supremacy
and then many many states Nina got a
theoretical questions that wants to look
at thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Mateus we have lots of time
for questions and we have a few which is
good thanks but Jesus that was a
beautiful talk I guess the question that
comes to mind after that what are they
not good for and and does their does
their excellent performance actually
Collin in the utility of small-scale
quantum simulators for a variety of
problems yeah so what I'll then I
suppose well that's exactly what we want
to find out for ground state it works so
well that I don't really know yet the
thing we should look at States they're
dull we should look at get highly faster
the ground states of models completing
phases to see whether there's a problem
there but but the but right now I think
the question there is more what
interesting for these problems can be
now finally solved with it or can we try
to solve and that way we will learn it
for dynamics it's pretty good but it's
not perfect after some time things break
down which is expected cause that's
really hard
so what to understand more kind of what
is the limit of quantum dynamics and how
far can it go there yeah I want to find
out the limit so that I know where it's
actually good and then I know exactly
what to apply it for that's it calling
to question the utility of quantum
simulators I think that what's all the
beautiful fully saw yesterday's for
those when to tend to talk by helmet
repetitive petrol pickup cover kind of
the arms race we have between quanto
simulators and vesicle machines and what
we've seen for quantum simulators does
just like- quantum gas I see in the past
is that just trying to validate them are
trying to match them or trying to beat
them even led us to develop lots of
new classical methods that really push
the piece forward for example for
simulating the hubbard model that was
around for 30 years and you got stuck
somewhere we got stuck simply because we
could not solve the high TC problem
which is kind of this holy grail out
there but with quantum simulators we had
easier goals can we solve the hubbard
model at higher temperatures than high
TC low temperatures and there we made
huge go-gurt for example there so think
that competition will rather clicking
new developments and will help both the
simulators by giving things and after
test after test after test after
validation and also the moment the
results differ that's where those
interesting science so I think it's it's
good for the field and no matter what
wins because I think both methods will
progress due to the competition and will
always need experiments to really grasp
what those methods calculated
so I'm wondering how surprised I should
be when I see results like this like
suppose that I know like the the
topological system yeah is exactly
described by pets yeah aren't pets like
strict subsets of these internet we have
so so there I wouldn't be but it is nice
to see the proof that is possible that
it can encode it a blow to your face
okay same with all this 1d stuff right I
mean it should with the 1d stuff
I'm a bit more surprised because okay
what this stuff in MPs will work for
sure yeah yeah when it says 1d locals
what I was not sure is even now don't
take this quantum mechanic wavefunction
answers but just the petition functional
of an item model cannot really learn
this 1d Quantico from stuff the
correlations yeah so seeing that it
works I'm not as surprised in hindsight
but then then it truly it was more and I
had this estimated how can you be sure
their works in 2d and 3d and because we
have these long-range couplings
we're not local so that that's when it
was no longer the bicycle is very easy
to include long-range entanglement the
correlations in the answers so the power
thing comes so we simplify the model by
going to a classical Ising model but we
give it more power by the long-range
couplings and if you checked like if
there's a comfort like if you can make
the the Boltzmann machine like slightly
more local and not lose any of those are
those are interesting questions to look
into that it would love to look into but
right now we have to build a quantum
computer at least that's what case that
tells me
hi Matias you have pointed out a larger
stronger expressive power of Boltzmann
machines compared to tensor nets with
bounded one dimension mpesa value right
so one factor I'm aware of in this
matter is the capacity of Boltzmann
machine for capturing one ranging
tunngle meant yeah in the data are you
aware of other factors that would work
towards explaining this separation I
think that's the best argument I see
I just wanted to ask you about how
there's the actual computation scale
compared to Sony NPF simulation or Apep
simulation as I as I grow the size of
the system with Monte Carlo simulations
the scaling is typically linear and the
volume so it has yeah a very good
calendar yeah when it's translational
events then it's even better than this
more like constant
so Matias this connection between say n
dimensional quantum system and n plus 1
dimensional like the connection between
an N dimensional classical sin
dimensional quantum system and plus 1
Jack words and classical n plus 1
quantum works for translation invariant
at least heisting models right so I can
always take a quantum Isaac model and
make it a classic Eliza model in one
more dimension yes and then so do we
have any rules for when I now make these
graphs kind of partially non-local like
what like it'd be nice if there is a map
between say classical lighting models on
graphs and hamiltonians they represent
is it that exists anybody know a key
would be nice to have such people that
understanding
great so let's thank Matthias again for
Rita and our final our final talk last
but not least of the day is from Bettina
hime she's going to tell us about
service codes under optimal decoding
yeah so good evening ask us the
responsibility of the last talk talk I
know you all want to go to dinner by now
so I thought it would be a good idea to
go into some more depth so you can
actually earn that dinner a bit we've
already heard a lot about quantum error
correction and because it seems like it
a lot of their architectures for quantum
computer you might have to rely on
quantum error correction to actually get
the necessarily fidelity to do practical
applications I will talk some more about
error correction now one of the
candidates of how you could do that is
always this idea of topological codes
and topological systems and the basic
idea is quite simple we want to encode
the information we're interested in into
something that is a little bit more
stable so we would like that our
information is encoded in the global
degrees of freedom that are not easily
changed by local perturbations when we
talk about error correction usually
these are active Corrections that will
apply at least memory to a system to to
get to stay to what we wanted to be so
in terms of this topological system you
could imagine that as being as
excitations being quite a particle
settings around your system and if
and the task of error correction is to
track your movement so that you can
determine when accidental breeding has
happened which would change your logical
state now the topic of this particular
talk they already had a very interesting
some interesting facts by the read on
error correction and I would like to
pick up where he left off which is the
decoding part and in particular I would
like to go into more details rather than
giving a good suggestion of how you
might do this in the most efficient way
I would like to take a step back and
think about how what we would like to do
ideally if we killed what would be the
optimal way or the best way to solve the
problem from there we can see what
consequences it has to make certain
approximation to make certain
assumptions to get to something more
practical so I realize that a lot of
these quick introductions come a bit
late in the day I apologize I didn't
plan for the order but I'll still
briefly just introduce because I have no
not quite everybody familiar with the
whole formalism so just to go very
quickly over it so the one thing I'm
going to be looking at in this talk are
surface notes that you've heard a lot
about already and they belong to a
particular family of error correcting
codes withdrawal stabilizer codes the
idea of this whole table is a formalism
is to describe the system by a set of
operators under which the state is
invariant so you get a group of
operators that tell you what your system
is going to look like and what you would
like to do is to do all your logical
computations inter simul taneous plus
one item please
if you can achieve that's been the nice
thing about that is that logical
information is not changed if I apply
any of those members and I can actually
detect local excitations by measuring
refers back to the eigen basis of those
operators so let's look at a bit more
concrete example tiny surface seventeen
code y 17 you're gonna see in a mess we
start out with nine data cuba and we're
going to encode k logical qubits which
is in this case for the nine cubed here
just one logical qubit so the nice thing
about service code is that they are
planar and we've got rather simple
checks
so our stabilizers in this case are
simple poly operators and they act only
on four cubed simultaneously so they're
actually doable in current hardware
but what we do some collective
measurements to extract that and the
collective measurements are usually done
in form of applying a short circuit on
to those four cubits and the Nutella
qubits to extract the value of the
operator we're supposed to measure now
measuring them cell a cubed will give us
each plus one or minus one and will give
us information about how about the
location of our quarter particles the
values that we measure are not unique to
a certain error so for example if I have
a particular error that error on the
qubit up there I might just as well have
one an error up there and still get the
same indication the rest marked and fill
a qubit to denote the error by
indicating it being minus 1 instead of
plasma on measurement so what the task
of a decoder is is to reconstruct
logical information that we include into
that system by measuring these joint
operators we actually protect their
stage back into the stabiliser state and
by eliminating the syndromes we'll get
it back to the code base so the decoder
is supposed to determine a correction
based on these measured values such that
the final stage is hopefully again the
correct logical state we want to
preserve now I told you we're going to
extract the measurement values by
applying a short-circuit this is the
particular short-circuit so of course
since the applies work with error can
occur during any time in the circuit and
can propagate so even though ideally we
would simply like to measure some
operations that gets us good information
about how our system looks like in
reality these measurements are not
necessarily correct so if I have some
error in between that circuit that error
will propagate because I'm applying
joint gates to two errors at the end
and that's generally what we mean when
we talk about circuit level noise and
the decoding I am talking about actually
is based on the complete noise model so
it takes every propagation into account
to do the best recoding that we can we
would it's very useful to think of
errors in terms of a certain
classification so what we can do is say
that we have a certain ideal syndrome
that we would like to obtain so when I
have a setter on a certain qubit there
are two syndromes in this case that
should pop up there is basically the
same as saying that the error is
assuming that error would occur at the
beginning of the syndrome extraction
circuit so any operation that eliminates
these values will actually map the state
back into the code space though because
it's not unique what errors might have
occurred the error pattern up here has
the exact same syndrome as the one
before we do not necessarily get the
correct logical state if we apply the
wrong correction in a sense we all have
changed the logical state of our system
so in addition to classifying the state
of our system according to the values
that we measure we also need to classify
it according to a value denoting its
logical state its current logical state
in addition to that we still have the
assumption that there are occurred right
at the beginning of the measurement
circuit which is not the case so it
could have been anywhere during this
circuit which means that the values that
we measured are not necessarily correct
so additionally to a logical operator we
also need to classify the data first
system according to the vet to the
measured value of our syndrome so to sum
this up we have some data qubits we have
some entelechy but we have basically an
ideal syndrome they classified the state
that our data qubits
currently in together with a logical
operation and we have the measured
syndrome that classifies the state that
our sinner
cubits are in so that's what gets a
complete description of our system that
also means we end up with a whole bunch
of equivalence class of errors in
general we end up with a probability
distribution of errors so the system is
completely described and all error
propagation by a probability
distribution across either qubits and
syndrome qubits so classifying that
error actually allows us to completely
describe this of error propagation that
occurs by a transition matrix that
describes the transition from one of
these close ups the one set of errors we
classified into another one most of
these entries of the matrix are actually
zero so we could describe it in terms of
a smaller matrix that depends on the
last method syndrome and the next
measured syndrome now I admit that
sounds all very technical so what does
that mean for our decoding so the
version metric syndrome values give us
our likely error location in a sense but
what we want to do is that we want to
find out in which equivalent class of
errors our current state is so we would
like to keep track of all error classes
that we have the issue with that is that
there are there are a lot of them in
particular we would have to care to
recalculate basically the whole
transition matrix for each part when we
do different logical operations we would
have to recalculate that transition
matrix each time also in general if we
have something more complex than poly
noise like amplitude damping then it
depends actually on the state of the
system so in reality it's simply not do
able to do that to sum things up
it's an np-hard problem to actually be
killed optimally so what we do what do
we do what we always do with empty heart
problems we'll define some approximation
to actually achieve the same thing
without actually tracking all the
equivalence classes of errors in the
case of surface code there's this
minimum rate perfect matching for
example that gives an efficient decoding
in the sense that is a polynomial time
decoding now polynomial time sounds nice
but again it doesn't mean very much
until you determine what polynomial
exactly means now it turns out it's
approximately with close distance to the
power of 4 I would argue but it still
seems like a bit much so one might hope
that there is a more efficient way and
the read scheme sounds really
interesting in that directory but the
more interesting question to come from
this perspective of what we would
actually like to do is what kind of
approximations make sense to you because
we have this large strong probability
distribution our task if we ever want to
have in it to achieve an efficient
decoding is to split that distribution
across all qubits into the product of
smaller distribution so how do we do
that now it is worth looking a bit into
the kind of approximations that you
could do and it turns out it's quite
practical to actually just use some mini
way perfect matching because it tends to
neglect certain things off that
distribution so I'll compare some
optimal decoded values with minimum
weight perfect matching to briefly tell
you what it actually is that I'm talking
about you can think of minimum ray
perfect matching as some sort of search
algorithm that determines a suitable
correction so each measured syndrome
change as interpreted as a vertex on a
graph and we assign weights between
vertices
what we then try to do when we have
certain values that pop up is that we
always match them in pairs that is very
reasonable in case of the surface coat
because any X or side arrow has two
results and syndromes popping up in
pairs more or less it's a bit less
reasonable if you think of something
like color codes so what you could do
there is just protect it down on to
surface cases good but that's basically
why this minimum rate perfect matching
is somewhat specific to surface could be
because it relies on defects arising in
pairs and ergo of course is to minimize
the total weight now this kind of
decoding is largely independent on the
noise type of strengths and strength
that we have which is nice because we
don't need to know anything about the
noise that we have in our system but one
might also hope that if we didn't know
what noise we had we could use that
information to do something better at
the same time so let's look at some
assumptions like look for example I
talked about that we want to track of
equivalence classes of errors so minimum
rate perfect matching replaces this
whole class by a representative in some
way by the element with the most weight
so in a sense we are not instead of
looking for a minimum in free energy we
are looking for a minimum in energy one
might wonder if that's a reasonable
approximation to make that we can simply
neglect entropic contributions another
thing is that one might wonder what
happens to different sorts of
correlations because these pairs well
because you match pairs the
possibilities to actually match groups
of sand drums is very limited so as I
have for example a Y error
I should not only have two syndromes
that pop up but in fact for yes I'm
still doing a matching of pairs always I
can adapt the weight based on some
matching is making it more likely to
match sets when I previously matched
access on the same qubit but so that's
already an improvement so it's very easy
to not do that
and instead say we're ignoring that
completely which means we will be
ignoring mm some correlations of errors
on the same qubit the wires we also
largely ignore correlations between
errors on different qubits and these are
much harder to account for when you set
the weight and what is most definitely
ignored are correlations between faulty
syndrome bets and faulty data qubits
because fundamentally we do a
phenomenological decoding when we do min
of a perfect matching and I can't come
up with a me throughout that how you
would adapt that the algorithm is not
designed to do that basically so the
first thing people usually look at when
talking about error correcting codes and
decoding is usually error thresholds so
some of you may have seen that plot
basically it's a reconstruction of an
older paper from oh nine where we get an
error threshold that is roughly 1% so
maybe to clear up some confusion and
might arise because we heard numbers
around 18% I think or even 39% the 1% is
if you actually look at the version
where the measurement can be faulty then
you end up with a much lower threshold
then if you assume that all your
measurements are perfect so what even is
an error error threshold so the reason
we are that interested in that value is
because below that threshold there years
that we can simply take more qubits and
get a better logical qubit so we can
trade-off physical qubits for for
reliability in a sense ideally so this
threshold depends on code on decoder and
the noise type the thing is we can there
are certain ways to determine it
analytically but not really for
realistic error models and not for
circuit level noise you can make
approximations for capacity or even for
phenomenological noise but not if you
actually consider a circuit
so correspondingly we also have no idea
what actually the best possible
threshold is that we could achieve which
is kind of an interesting question now
that one I can answer you pretty quickly
and it turns out for this particular
noise model
you wouldn't get over 1.8% no matter how
you do your decoding so the actual value
that you see in the plot is bit below
that because it already does one
approximation is split the decoding of
the set pipes idolises and the x hypeee
sterilizes simply because otherwise we
needed around 140 gigabyte of memory it
seems a bit much so it split and hence
the estimate but it looks like something
around 1.5 1.8% which is great because
that's definitely in the range that our
physical qubits are currently get enough
so the noise model that these values
refer to is more or less at the
polarizing channel but it has some
correlations on t-nut gates so each of
the two cubed errors during the scene
update is equally likely so in that
sense it's not a none corollary that
north north model but a correlated one
and the good news is that there we
actually do see the difference between a
decoding that does not know anything
about the noise model or the circuit and
just blindly assumes nothing and apply
the correction compared to a decoding
that has full information and uses all
that information but one might wonder
that if there is no information that I
could use if there are no correlations
that are interesting or heard that it's
in sometimes it's easier to have
correlations because it means you have
information about your system now if you
don't have those one might wonder if
this perfect decoding is still better
than simply blinded you a matching
because in a sense that's exactly the
type of noise that minimum will be very
perfect matching is perfect for now the
thing is in a realistic setting because
we do have this little circuit
to expect the syndromes we always going
to have some correlations so we look at
a narrow model that in a sense is
completely uncorrelated in the sense
that each arrow on each qubit is
independent but we still do the circuit
we still have some correlations because
we propagate errors we also switch from
a six step circuit to an eight step
circuit but these are minor reductions
and what we end up with is definitely
less less of a difference between the
two but still visibly there's there
still a distinct difference between the
two values now if you look for minimum
of a perfect matching we can obviously
get more data and actually look if the
threshold there observe threshold chips
as we actually have as we actually go to
larger two distances and based on that
we would estimate that the threshold
values are around 0.28% or 0.35 percent
maximally which is already a lot lower
than before so that's not quite an order
order of magnitude but still it's a lot
lower than the correlated noise model so
it seems reasonable that we should be
using correlations actually change
seemed reasonable to wish that we had a
system that was in some way correlated
to exploit that but the question is
which correlation because they are also
kind of hard to include in the decoding
scheme so let's switch to looking at how
important different contributions could
potentially be now if we stick with
minimal perfect matching we had our ball
as symmetric depolarizing channel so in
this case it's actually as a polarizing
channel no correlations between peanuts
for arrows on scene updates and if we
compare that with the results for
independent X and set errors there's
absolutely no difference which is not
very surprising because again minimum a
perfect matching doesn't make use of the
information that there are correlations
it does the same thing for
nice ones although if you look at
something slightly more complex like a
literal approximation which is still
efficient then you find it also here
results match reasonably well so it
doesn't seem to make a huge difference
if I have correlations between errors on
the same qubit those do not seem to be
very relevant in a sense or very bad if
we don't know about them so one might
wonder what happens that we have
correlations between Arizona different
qubits that we don't know about which
seems like a realistic scenario
approximation of an amplitude damping
Channel sorry didn't know there were
different ones so one might wonder what
happens if you have correlations between
errors on different data qubits and one
simply simply one convenient way to
actually generate interesting
correlations is to take a really bad
syndrome extraction circuit so far we
worked with this nice circuit that
minimizes error propagation now if we
switch to something slightly differently
we're going to end up that this with
something that is far less favorable for
a decoder because instead of having
error propagation in perpendicular cura
logical operators basically that don't
matter
we now have propagation in the direction
that a single qubit error could
potentially result in a logical error
for this entry code already so if we
take an extraction circuit like that
which basically results in a correlated
noise model we're going to see that
that's already a lot harder to handle
for something that doesn't know about
that or doesn't use that information on
the other hand if we stick with our
perfect decoding there's absolutely no
no sign of that behavior
because we still do know perfectly well
what our system does its invincible
possible to perfectly account for those
propagate
and adapt accordingly so that seems like
one interesting thing to consider when
we are constructing approximation
because ultimately once we get somewhere
below threshold what we're interested in
is or what has a large impact in orders
of magnitude asymptotic behavior so it's
an absolute way to have a distance bank
code if our behavior actually but the
behavior of our code is like it is in
size code simply because we don't
actually do a reasonable decoding
another thing that I mentioned before is
that I mean all these things in
principle even for that syndrome
extraction sequence even with mini way
perfect matching there are ways to adapt
so as long as you know about those
correlations although as a matching
algorithm you could adapt your way to
and that behavior no longer occurs the
one thing that I told previously what
you can't really do is account for
correlations between syndrome qubits and
data qubits so the question is are those
having a major impact so what we could
do is to to test that hypothesis is that
instead of working with our probability
distribution across our whole system we
could split that distribution into two
parts one for the data qubits and one
for the syndrome qubit so basically we
replace our models of all Cruise's there
by the singly left coset and
additionally simply a probability to
have an error for the measurement if we
do that surprisingly there's actually
still it it looks fairly well the
absolute value is slightly worse but
there's still a good as in topic
behavior so it doesn't have to it
doesn't seem to have a significant
impact on unhoused for small error a
behavior which is great
so what are the things we looked at and
we found so we looked at how important
entropy contributions are and we looked
at how important different correlations
are we looked at in particular as the
correlations between Aragon design
qubits between eras on different qubits
and between errors and syndrome and data
qubits of those types of errors what we
really need to worry about are
correlations between different qubits so
these are the correlations we do need to
know about to some extent and that need
to be handled by the decoder in a
reasonable way the good news is that if
we do that we actually end up with a
higher threshold than if we just had
independent noise or we were likely to
end up with a higher threshold which is
great so quick reminder for the
threshold values that's where we had it
seems reasonable to do and the results
that are presented here is in sometimes
give absolute upper bounds there's
literally no way to better detailed
there other noise models certainly that
could potentially have higher thresholds
but apart from that that's where we need
to get so what does it mean when we're
thinking about moving to actual hardware
so the main issue is that or that it
seems to me that there might be
correlations we don't know about those
are very problematic because it's very
hard to design a blind decoder that
behaves reasonable for all sorts of
correlations so to some extent we do
need to know what kind of correlations
we should be expecting and we should
adapt for on the other hand at the
trade-off between having to determine
how your system behaves which is
expensive and hard to do and everything
and the gain that we actually get from
it so determining whether or not I have
some Y correlations seems like a waste
of time
but on one hand there's there's
innocence there's the trade-off between
the classical and quantum complexity the
more we know about or knowledge modeling
the better we're come for it
the last qubits we probably need to
achieve the same result as if we don't
do that and if we just do a very fast
but very crude decoding we can take a
larger distance code - we might not end
up with the performance that we would
actually expect so in a way larger speak
to make sense when we do have a
reasonable tutorial on one hand but the
decoders will need to be fast enough to
actually decode so probably there's a
sweet spot in between where we don't
have huge code distances and not tiny
ones that we can still process
classically as as far as determining the
noise model gills it turns out knowing
the structure of your noise knowing
which correlations occur are fairly
important whereas knowing what actually
your noise parameter czar seems far far
less important now the data wasn't shown
but actually modifying what
probabilities our optimal decoder
expects versus what probabilities it
gets didn't change basically anything in
the data so for at least these are very
simple noise models that were tested but
at least produce it seems to be less
relevant to actually know the absolute
values what seems to be relevant is to
know their relative values what is more
likely what kind of structure we
actually expect and it also seems that
it should be a very easy and
straightforward thing to account for a
syndrome extraction circuit this is
information we get for free so we should
use it and even though for service codes
it's fairly easy to find a syndrome
extraction circuit that doesn't
propagate errors and in that sense it's
not easier to do that there are other
codes where you simply can't find this
this particularly nice way of extracting
symptoms so that's one thing we should
look out for
so in those now I would like like to
thank Michael
operators and you definitely deserve
dinner
[Applause]